uh folks there is trouble Brewing I am
in a very much trouble right now Glenn
Greenwald and Brianna Joy gray are
coming for me because I don't think
Marianne Williamson is a good candidate
uh let's back up a little bit
um I tweeted yesterday that I see a lot
of Tulsi gabbard energy
moving towards Marianne Williamson there
were a bunch of people who fell for
Tulsi in 2020 and now of course that
she's like an anti-vaxx Republican CPAC
speaker you know it's completely
unhinged what's happened with Tulsi some
of the tool C people have realized all
right we got to get away from Tulsi
let's go behind someone else and so some
of that energy is moving behind Marianne
Williamson now I know that in 2020 Glenn
Greenwald was at least a casual fan of
Tulsi I have no idea on Brianna Joy gray
I'm not super familiar with her I think
she's come up once before on the show
like a couple years ago but I don't know
too much about her so we did a segment
where I told you as I always do because
I'm honest I'm not gonna pretend right I
told you I'm not super impressed with
Marianne Williamson's candidacy I think
she has every right to run
anybody who wants to run should this is
America she should be able to present
her views she should run as a Democrat
or as an independent or as a republican
whatever she wants I defend it I support
it this is what America is about and I
also mentioned that personally it's not
for me her woo-woo pseudoscience
background isn't for me she has the
right ideas on a number of political
issues but that doesn't mean I would
make her president she has no experience
she has no expertise she has no
qualifications and she is no
um sort of understanding of the way
politics works so might you go to like a
Reiki practitioner and they're like hey
I'm for Medicare for all great doesn't
mean you make them president doesn't
mean you support them in a primary but
that's all I was saying and anybody is
free to do of course whatever they want
Glenn Greenwald didn't like
Glenn Greenwald responded to this on
Twitter by saying quote those quotes
Marianne Williamson quotes I read that
sounded like Deepak Chopra Glenn says
those quotes aren't remotely kooky
they're reflective of someone engaging
the vast mysteries of Life via
spirituality and Transcendence but to
utterly conventional midwits he's
talking about me to utterly conventional
midwits serving as normalcy enforcers
David packman
anything beyond New York Times op-ed
page drek seems quote crazy so Glenn
doesn't agree with me
and then Brianna Joy gray who I think is
a podcaster
um and I guess is in League with some of
these folks I'm not super familiar with
her she tweets about this in response to
Glenn Biden guy wants to vote for Biden
again this is why part of the left is
dead and it's like which are you talking
about the only part of the left that
ever wins that ever quite literally ever
wins she's saying that part of the left
is dead
the only part that ever wins anything oh
okay very interesting as far as I know
that tweet was not particularly well
received and Brianna subsequently
deleted it okay so let's again just make
sure we're all on the same page Biden
wasn't my guy in the primary
I'm just not delusional okay Marianne
Williamson has no experience relevant to
being president of the United States if
you tell me hey you know what David we
have too many like lawyers
who are presidents or business people
who are President we need people from
different backgrounds
I'm with you I want scientists as
presidents I want you know people who
have led non-profits would be great uh
for presidents uh I would like to see
people from the field of Education be
present there's all I'm with you we have
two narrow a scope for people that
eventually become president but Marianne
Williamson has no relevant experience no
relevant expertise no qualifications and
also none of the relationships that
would make you a more effective
president she's for Medicare for all
that's great
she believes climate change should be
taken seriously great but she's not
going to push Biden to the left because
she's not even going to debate Biden if
Biden runs for re-election there's not
going to be a real primary she's not
going to debate Biden if you came to me
and you said David Katie Porter oh now
we're talking okay now we're talking if
you said David Stacy Abrams not only an
extremely skilled organizer but deep
policy knowledge and understands the
system I Stacy Abrams absolutely
uh but Marianne Williamson is not for me
so
if the sort of followers of people in
the Greenwald Universe catch wind of
this they'll probably come after me
pretty hard but uh I'm completely
comfortable with that bring it on this
is my view Marianne Williamson I support
her having a candidacy if that's what
she wants gosh darn it there's nothing
more American than that but it's just
not for me one of our sponsors is paired
the app for couples every day paired
gives you and your partner questions
quizzes games to have fun to stay
connected to deepen your conversations
and get to know each other better what's
great about it is you don't even have to
be in the same room especially with the
baby right now my girlfriend and I are
quite busy and paired really helped us
to stay connected you get a daily
question to answer you can't see your
partner's answer until you answer
yourself and their questions about
everything relationship life intimacy
other things and all of the exercises
were developed by academic psychologists
and expert relationship therapists as
well questions like what makes you feel
lucky in your relationship great when
you want to remember and have gratitude
a really great thing what's an activity
you could try together this month
actually gets people thinking about
things to do it can go in really funny
directions as well but it just always
feels like time well spent head over to
paired.com Pacman for a seven day free
trial and 25 off a subscription the link
is down below